saying
when it comes to marriage
marriage is your goal yes
are this generation like i was saying
ready for marriage
you were saying that there's not enough
role models i think there's not enough
templates because you were talking about
manual where do we find that manual i
can't lie do you see all the celebrities
that people glorify like and who are
married just like beyonce
rihanna
like there's even so
certainties are different because they
live a different life but
they're getting married mm-hmm they're
getting married but then when people um
glorify
other people's relationships yeah that's
what i think is part of the downfall
because every relationship is different
differently yeah yeah and so what
happens is do you guys know um
uh derrick jackson you see what happened
with the guy derrick jackson terry
jackson jackson oh yeah
he was he was like
right so he was like do you remember the
story like he was like a
a dating coach
and he would tell women how to get their
man and he was married yeah right tell
women how to get their man told them all
of this kind of stuff as a married man
that's what you need to do
this guy was cheating cheating
right so women would women would
think oh oh my god that's exactly the
relationship that i want to be like
meanwhile this guy's having sex with
whoever he wants to have sex with right
so
when you say there's no template
i always say
your relationship is individual yeah
when people have the hashtag
relationship goals i'm like you do not
know what's going on inside that
relationship anyone can take a picture
for instagram
and show what their relationship looks
great you know what it is
that's what's wrong with our like
generation it's all about image bro
like even with youtube couples they
glorify that youtube couple like
being being a couple is this nice thing
oh there's hardship behind that yeah
teamwork
and because that's what like that's what
people see and that's what we're exposed
to that's what we just think that is i
feel like when it comes i feel like
madrid are people on generation when it
comes to that hardship they don't have
to deal with it that's why you have
these relationships where they break up
for five months you've got a person that
has a that has like
up to like ten relationships one like
with one guy one girl that's what i'm
saying is they don't know how to do that
it's weak there's no foundation behind
right so then like i said if this
generation isn't
if they don't have something to go by
as young people because i know when i
was growing up yeah i'm a little bit
older than you guys when i was growing
up i had
that model to look to i had
people in my life that were married
in your life as young people do you have
people in your life that around you that
are married
um
um
recently yes growing up no
uh
with me
yes i do
but like
i'll say now today
not as much but i feel like i don't need
to rely on them people i don't either
but i think
i think my point came from i think when
you're talking when we're looking at the
original video the woman is talking
about how she is succeeding as a wife
and we were talking a lot about okay
what makes a good wife how what what
should a wife look like and you even
mention the word manual that's what i'm
going by and i'm saying okay cool
where do we find that information of yes
we're talking about femininity but where
do we find that information as to what a
good wife should look like
if we're not seeing those templates okay
cool all right
i don't want to misquote misquote kevin
samuels but
from us
from us
but
today nouns is like today's generation
you guys like you don't listening to men
is a bad thing you know what i mean
well i would say that the women of this
generation are quite unruly they don't
listen to men they don't um a man
speaking
is
now remember
women of this generation talk a lot
about men
a lot meditation men are that mean this
man
a guy puts his hand up like i'm a man
can i weigh in
no you're just a man yeah
hang on a minute you're talking about my
gender
like can i try and give you some input
no you're not allowed to so what happens
is
women of this generation stay within
their echo chambers and they create all
of these things around what men are and
they've never really asked men exactly
what men want and then when men do tell
you what they want they don't listen
they're misogynistic yeah you're
patriarchal you're this you're that you
want women to be back in the 1920s and
you want them to be your slaves it's
like men
have not really changed
what they want from a woman for like 100
years thousands of years even they want
it like you said they want a submissive
woman um ali got it right right they
want to they want someone who's feminine
they want someone who's cooperative when
kevin samuel said that the world went
absolutely crazy
you know what even to the women that do
you even pass on that knowledge on other
women do you know what other women call
them pick me pick me pick me up
i saw i checked ali's profile she had
pick me nation in her um so it's just
it's just it's it's not even a loser
situation i am the day what's the ladies
name again in the video ali ali ali is
getting the last laugh she's as she said
she's living the life she's
she's getting her back like i said
tonight but because sorry go on there no
no
because i generally think women don't
listen um i think women have a hard time
list they listen to other women and eat
and i tell you something like you said
the reason why the term pick me came up
is because when they hear something that
doesn't echo the same thing they've been
hearing for amount of time about what
men are like they call them pygmies so
men tend to be more logical
it can come off quite harsh to women i i
don't you know i don't deny that like
kevin samuels kevin samuels they said oh
he's too harsh when he says it yeah but
is what he's saying was true truth
that's the truth that's what people
that's what we talk about as men like
behind closed doors and in barbers
that's what we
you want to know what we talk about
that's what we talk about that's what we
want and men would a man would let you
know that you've got a bug in your nose
yes
you've got a bogey there bro
a woman will let you roll with that but
a woman let another woman roll with that
bulgy and be like oh i don't want to oh
oh i don't want to tell her and if she
does tell her oh what's she doing that
for why is she doing that they have this
i've and i've said
generally i don't think
women like other women
and when i say that i'll mean this
go get one and the reason why i say i
don't think women like other women is
because
as a woman yeah
if you get if we were to bring in
three more women in here right now
instantly the women are going to be
sizing you up
they can be looking at your hair
they're going to be looking at your
shoes they're going to be looking at
what you're wearing
and in their head they're creating a
whole scenario of
what kind of woman is this
and when you start speaking they're
going to be like oh what she thinks that
she's this yeah
women generally see other women as
competition yeah right and so what
happens is is that what happens when
women don't like other women
is that because of the competitive
nature yeah
they who were they competing for
they're competing for men
the man
so a woman will look at your jacket and
be like oh
this is that that's not even the right
shade of brown
it's true
i've seen it
they were saying
they'll make beef out of nothing
which is why women change their friends
every day every every three months every
new circle because because women don't
like other women they see other women as
competition the only time men see men as
competition is when it comes to success
yeah yeah they don't see a man i'm not
looking at your hair thinking i'm bored
oh man's got hair
it's just like he's just different from
me you know i mean i just think women
generally do not like other women and i
think that plays into like the dating
market in marriage and i think that's
the reason why ally
got so much hate because they're not
they're not in her position right and
they're hating on that right because
they want to be i agree you know i mean
but they ain't gonna say that because
they're on social media they're gonna
hate have you found as a woman yourself
that women look at you
and hate yes
yeah and there you go yeah
and why do you think that is is that
because of your looks success or both of
the above both
um yeah both
like men like i said i've said men
um in general now becoming a little bit
more feminine
where they start looking at a man's
looks
like oh well he's looking like this is
that bro men don't do that
like stop that like i don't care about
what a man looks like if you want to
look at bill gates or you want to look
at steve jobs
they're looking at a man you look at
jay-z but we're looking at his success
we don't care what jay-z looks like we
care that he's got a billion in the bank
that's what we care about we don't care
about the fact that he looks different
so
i think yeah when it comes to
competition men and women have different
competitions and i think um in the
dating market and the marriage market
personally going back to the video i
think the reason why ali was receiving
so much hate is because women
one probably saw her probably thought
that she was you know attractive i'm
probably hating on that they won't say
it though they won't say yeah it's true
i saw women in the comments section
saying what can't she get a better dress
what's the point of the vid does that
relate i was like yo where's my
correlation like not even not even like
involving with the context and i've i've
realized that actually when i talk about
some of the things i talk about on um
my videos there will literally be people
who just start mentioning random things
mainly women i mean sometimes it has
been men sometimes it has been right
okay but it's mainly women yeah they'll
be like oh why's your head like that oh
why did you do that oh this i'm like but
that's not the point like does it really
matter like if what i'm saying if it's a
60-second clip of me talking and all
you're focusing on is how i look yes
it's like what because that's women for
you
isn't it it's competitive i've seen that
too because there were there was a
comment on um on ali's video right and
they were saying um oh you sound like
you can kind of be taken advantage of if
you're a housewife right you could be
taking advantage of and if that man
decides to quote unquote cancel you yeah
from the relationship what are you gonna
do
right so i think a lot of women in this
generation have a fear
of marriage
[Music]
because they feel like if you go into a
relationship with fear
your bounds are familiar you're bound to
vote you know what is i said this i've
been i've been saying this for a long
time life is about risk you know fact
you understand if you
if you go into a relationship hoping
that like
thinking of like oh what if this happens
well it's going to happen
you know what i mean
just take that risk because make sure it
don't happen make your partner happy
oh my god that is such a good point you
know how many times i've seen people
talk about like when it comes to
commitment inside oh yeah but this went
wrong that went wrong if you really want
it you will make it work you know what
is you know a lot of people do people um
go into new relationships with past
trauma
and
when
when people do that their past trauma
creeps up in them so much
and they don't know that they're
bringing that trauma that is gonna [ __ ]
up the new relationship you understand
i feel like people need to
you know what
i've been saying this
therapy
therapy therapy like even though therapy
is like you have to pay for therapy very
that therapy helps you out a lot man
because it makes you realize
like problems within yourself that you
that you haven't that you don't know on
your surface level of your brain i just
completed six months of therapy just to
put that out there
there you go